Let's just do it. You're going to do
it. Okay. It's just freaking do it. Hey,
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert
Krulwich, Radiolab, the pod guests.
[inaudible] today's topic is, um, well,
you know what, something you just did.
I didn't, I had my eyes closed the
whole time. Aw, you gave it away.
You know what I'm about to say? Pretend
you don't know what I'm saying. Okay.
Today's topic is, um, something
you just did actually what?
Yeah, that you did. You did it again
there in there. I don't know what it is.
There's something with my fingernails.
No, no. In there something. What?
Tell me. Okay. You blinked. Oh,
it's about, do you ever wonder, um,
I know this about blinks. This is
interesting, right? When you blink,
you should,
if you really understand what's going
on since a little bit of darkness,
cause after all your eyes are
closed for an instant of time,
but you don't because your mind
erases the darkness of the blink.
So you can blink away, but the world
will seem seamless and blink less to you.
Even though your observers
will see you blinking,
you will not feel the blink inside.
Do you ever wonder what is the actual
purpose of the blink to wet in your
eyeball? I assume? Well, that's
what they tell you in ninth grade,
but actually you would
think of that is the case.
They don't really humid days or let's
say in the sauna you would blink less
because it's very human and now
you don't have the right thing.
But very dry days, I would
blink more. Yeah, they've,
they've actually done studies where
they put people in Saunas and they've at
measured the rate of their blinks
in there. It doesn't change. Oh,
so there's something else
[inaudible] reason for the blend.
And so that's what we want to explore
in this podcast. Why you do we blink?
Actually, the answers are
completely fascinating.
Who are you going to ask this question to?
A great scientist that blink cologists
you will meet a blink ologists shortly.
But first I want to take you
to a guy who who uh, well he,
he's a blink. Colleges
have a different story.
Let's say he doesn't really
study blinks per se, but he,
when we sort of stumbled into it.
My name is Walter Murch.
I'm a film editor and I've been working
as a both as a film editor and as a
sound mixers since the late 1960s
Walter Merchant's edited some
amazing films, apocalypse now,
the godfather cold mountain.
He's really one of the great editors
in modern cinema. Oh, well thank you.
Thank you.
And he's also a great thinker about
editing and he tells the following story
about a discovery that he made while
working on one of his early films.
Well, this was many years ago. Uh,
when I was editing Francis
Coppola was the conversation
[inaudible],
which by the way is another great,
great movie was I think
1972 1973 and in the movie,
Gene Hackman plays a surveillance expert.
He spends the whole movie essentially
trying to decode this one conversation
that he's recorded. So
Walter marches there,
he's in the editing suite trying
to put it all together. He was
working late at night, all myself
on this old editing machine,
making a tape go and go
backwards. And forwards.
Oh look, that's terrible.
Cut Dead on a park bench.
And I was editing a scene when gene
Hackman is a get him for Christmas.
Yeah, he's already got the tapes. Okay.
What he's listening to in his laboratory,
what's a bit of a Meta moment actually,
because on screen gene Hackman
is editing tape and in his room,
Walter merge his editing tape
of Gene Hackman editing tape.
A lot of fun. You know,
every scene in a movie,
even simple scenes require tons of cuts
because as a viewer you're constantly
being bounced around from one camera
angle to the next, into the next.
And though it seems like what you're
watching is a continuous performance from
the actor.
It's actually been cobbled together
by the editor from dozens of takes.
So Walter Merchant's doing
this, he's editing this scene,
cut by laborious cut and it's important
to understand he's making every cut by
feel. What I will do is
run the film at full,
his mother mother's from try
to feel the rhythm, you know,
almost musical way and
right when he's ready,
who you there? Hit the cut
button and then rewind.
Run the film again and cut.
And if I've hit that cut button
on the same frame twice in a row,
that tells me that I'm
probably where I should be.
So he is editing this scene
together, takes many days. He says,
and somewhere along the way he
begins to get this creeping sense,
you know, when you're in a room and
maybe there's a leak outside and you,
there's a little drip,
drip, drip going on.
I began to get the sense that,
uh,
that there were some
collaboration going on between
myself and in this case gene Hackman
cause he would find, he says that
every time he made it, yeah. Cut.
He would see that on the screen. Gene
Hackman would have blinked [inaudible]
you mean your cuts kept falling
smack in the middle of his blinks?
Oh yeah. Wow. When I saw
it, well this is peculiar.
Am I responding to him blinking? Oh,
it didn't seem like that it was
possible and yet the alignment was um,
consistent
[inaudible]
so Walter merged,
developed a theory that maybe blinking
has very little to do with [inaudible]
moisture or any of that.
Maybe it's a kind of hidden
punctuation to thought
we're storytelling.
Thank you so much for agreeing to do
this and this is a very cool idea,
but it's just an idea
and we wanted to know
if there's anything to this
scientifically. Can you,
can you do me a favor and introduce
yourselves? Yes, yes. Tell them me first,
but then we found out about
these two Japanese researchers
who were nice enough to Skype with
us. My name is Tami Nakano and
[inaudible] in the cognitive neuroscience.
My name is [inaudible] and
she was a student of mine.
Okay. Tell me how mommy's going to talk
and bring is [inaudible]. Very common,
very common phenomenon,
but the purpose of rank is military.
Now the reason we had called to mommy
and sugar was because they had just
completed an experiment which they hoped
would solve this mystery of blinking
and what they did was they got a bunch
of subjects together and they hooked each
person up to a kind of Gizmo.
We put two electrodes, one
above and one below the eye.
And when we blink,
we can recall very strong electrical
signal and we can later analyze
automatically when the subject blinked.
This is actually what it sounds like
when a person blanks and once they had
everybody hooked up,
they played them a movie.
Each puzzle I present the
movie full street time.
Which movie
did you use by the way? Uh,
Ms Debbie. British quantity.
Okay. Mr. Bean, if you don't
know the movie, I didn't.
It's kind of like a farce. So that
means that bean is the Mr. Bean because,
uh, the story is easily
understand without sound.
The reason she took out
the sand was for, well,
it's actually not that interesting
why she took out the sound.
What they did was they watched people
watching movies, recorded their blanks.
Each time they watched and what
they found was really weird.
First thing they noticed
within each person, uh,
Dave's blink at the same
time point in the movie,
meaning people when they watch the movie
many times tend to always blink in the
same spots,
but weirder than that. Also
the timing of breach occurred.
At the same time between people,
they found a large percentage of
their subjects actually fell in sync.
They began to blink at the exact
same moment in the movie. Oh,
often did synchronization
occurred between people.
Uh, so, uh, according
to [inaudible] analysis,
one third of
blinks contributed to synchronization.
Just to appreciate that. I mean,
imagine you're sitting in a movie
theater with 200 other people,
dark, the movie starts,
action gets on the way and you're just
there watching and with each unconscious
blink that you make 70 people
make that blink right with you.
Like all these little butterfly wings
fluttering at the same time. Oh yeah.
Yeah. Wow.
And so they, uh, this was the question
was why, why does this happen? And uh,
yeah, they analyze their data
with that question in mind.
What they found is that what seems
to be happening is that people,
as they watched the movie,
get in sync with the story.
They intuit the narrative flow sort of
peaks in the valleys of the tail and
they're able to align their blinks
so that they fall right in the gaps.
Those little micro beets where
nothing happens. Yes. We found that,
uh, uh,
rink synchronizes occurred at the
conclusion of a action by the OCTA.
We start by Mr [inaudible].
She gave a bunch of examples.
One example is the empty street.
There's a moment in the film,
she says where all you see is this empty
street for just a few frames just to
beat.
And that moment everybody blinks these
streets or you know when Mr. Bean walks
into a room, closes the door,
right as the door finishes closing,
everybody blinks.
So these sound like rest stops.
If they were the New Jersey turnpike
is be where you'd go in and get your
coffee. Exactly. Say if it's
an eyeball, you just blinked.
One reason is that, uh,
we don't want to miss
very important point in,
in the story [inaudible] hypotheses is
that you see blinking is related to the
punctuation. Our ways of thinking.
Maybe there is some kind
of synchronization of the
thinking of the editor or
film maker, uh, that might, uh, you see,
make us blink at the same time.
Huh. But still, there's a white
question here like,
cause why would we even need to do that
in a blink and no one knows really.
But it may be that we blink at all because
we can only process life in chunks.
Might Be Chow, make a
tanking of the uh, role of,
of information now for effective
processing information processing or a
effective memorizing
in computer terms. It's like
that moment when we saved a dish
was enough information in
our buffer so to speak.
And now we think I've got to remember
this and that's at that moment that we
blink. Huh? That's what Walter
Mertz. Thanks. But who knows? Oh,
it's popping a new tape
every time you blink. Yeah,
because I noticed that culturally,
um, when you feel that you are done,
you know enough changes over time.
Like my daughter will watch a Cary grant
movie and the character played by Cary
grant will be in bed,
throw off the covers,
put his feet on the floor, get up and
then walk to the door. The whole thing.
She thinking like, come on, come on guy.
Just she wants it to calm and go
chunk and go. And so I don't know.
She's blinking madly Susie, but she's
clearly frustrated because she knows her.
Yeah.
I'm not sure that the chunking
isn't an artifact of where,
how you see when you're alive, like when
you're alive. Yeah. I wonder if the,
if the blink rates have changed over
over generations, I'm sure they have
two years of darkness, which you are,
which thanks to your lovely brain.
You're totally unaware of missing.
Thank you Brad. Thank you, ray.
I am, I'm getting up.
I'm rod and I remember call it Radiolab
is supported in part by the Sloan
Foundation, the corporation for
public broadcasting and one other.
We have one other, the biggest one in the
mall, the National Science Foundation.
Yes. Before we close,
I just want to thank Tim Howard for
production help on this podcast and I want
to urge everyone listening right now.
If you're only a podcast listener,
I don't know,
call your NPR station or check their
website for listings cause we might be on
your radio right now.
[inaudible].